madame monsieur bonsoir la première
classe dans le métro sentais un peu trop
le privilège elle n'était plus rentable
en outre à l'été la cible favorite des
tagueurs trois bonnes raisons pour la
supprimer
et la classer au rayon souvenirs en
compensation la ratp bonne fille va
faire un geste en faveur des personnes
âgées
principales victimes de cette abolition
christine meyrals guinée vers quelques
wagons de 1ère subsiste encore mais la
première classe et bien morte
aujourd'hui 80 % des usagers du métro
approuvent cette suppression mais les
autres les femmes enceintes les
handicapés et surtout les personnes
âgées la regrettent certains évoquent
déjà avec nostalgie le temps des
premières classes on avait plus de
facilité avoir une place assise dans les
premières et dans les autres voitures
c'était moins chargé mais moi j'aime
bien la trouver parce que l'amendement
surtout prendre direction au marché le
commerce de paris afin d'éviter tout
désaffection la ratp se mobilisent
les usagers sont invités à aider tous
ceux qui ont des difficultés à rester
debout de mesures vont être prises une
première mesure très simple qui consiste
à mieux signaler les places qui sont
réservés aux personnes pour qui la
station debout pénible et il y en a une
sur quatre par voiture est également une
campagne d'information pour bien
informer l'ensemble des voyageurs de
l'existence de ces places
la ratp a vite donc au civisme mais pour
quelques défenseurs du droit des usagers
cela ne suffit pas de désagrément
dénoncer les difficultés pour accéder
aux places assises pendant les heures de
pointe
mais la suppression de la première
classe n'est pas pour autant remise en
cause
nous proposons autre chose j'ai grand
place et la voiture de première par une
voiture métro confort réservé à toutes
les personnes que les écouter a marché a
cédé du côté de la ratp on affirme que
cette solution n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour la ségrégation pourrait être mal
perçu par les premiers concernés
ceux ci n'ont donc plus qu'à espérer que
les jeunes et les bien portants
respecteront leurs droits